John Green: Here we go!
AAAHHHHH!
John: Why did you put fart fart fart up with-
yeah.
Hank Green: I just — I decided that I would
have a lower third.
Hank: How about this?
John: No, that's — that's just four farts.
Hank: I briefly heard that you guys promised
that you would eat a bowl of crickets if we
raised $10,000.
Steve Zaragoza: That was this guy!
Right here!
Matt Lieberman: I said I would eat it!
Hank: ...Crunchy.
Hank: There's a lot of fingers happening now!
Uuuuhhhh that one's mine!
Hank: Hannah, is this your sweatshirt?
Hannah Hart: OH, YES!
Now-
Hank: This is as good as I can do.
I guess I probably should have unzipped it.
Rhett McLaughlin: My mom, she does not know
who you are.
John: If you donate $10,000 in the next hour,
Sarah and I are going to cover our faces in
peanut butter.
I gotta take off my shirt if I'm gonna dance.
Michael Aranda: This is a perfect opportunity
to confess my love for John Green.
Henry Reich: There is a piece of aerogel.
John: Keep your Batman mask on, though, so
you can be the Masked Avenger.
Never do this... unless you have explicit
permission.
How about my cheek?
Is that enough, or should we do more?
Henry Green: Uh...
That's enough.
Reid Reimers: For those here who haven't met
Lollipop, can you describe why we are willingly
having a skunk in this room with us right
now?
Jessi Knudsen Castañeda: 'Cause she's awesome!
John: He's covered in poop!
Henry: I KNOW!
Craig Benzine: This is a phase of time when
I didn't have a beard.
Hank: Just to let you know, we're talking
about butts.
Felicia Day: It's a heiney!
A derriere!
A badonkadonk.
That's my favorite.
That's the, uh, scientific term?
John: We're just $160 away from a million,
Hank!
So when we get to a million, Grace is gonna
dress up like a Christmas tree, and Sarah
is gonna do my makeup, and you can do whatever
you want.
It seems to me that the donations have slowed
dramatically!
Apparently everyone is getting an error who's
trying to donate right now.
Hank: Did we crash all of Indiegogo??
John: No one's been able to donate in nine
minutes.
We just got a little bit, we're inching-
OH WE DID IT!
WE DID IT!
YEEEEES!
(Much yelling)
Sarah Green: Oh, Grace, the star...
John: Aw, Grace, that makes it, the star makes
it.
Grace Helbig: Thank you.
I'm a great actress.
Emily Graslie: I want to see the horse.
Destin: The horse.
Okay.
Emily: I like horses.
Equus ferus caballus.
Destin: Oh, woah, there's a word there!
Hank: Fart!
It says fart!
It says buts fart!
Matthew Gaydos: So is your concept that you're
a baby?
Hank: No!
I'm a space alien, obviously!
Alli Speed: Oh my gosh, it is like a little
onesie!
I feel like I'm watching something I- that's
very private.
Matthew: Neither baby nor alien.
He was BUTFARTMAN.
Hank: You gotta find two shirts that are very
similar, wear one on the top and one on the
bottom, and you, too, can be Butfartman!
Wil Wheaton: I'll be right back.
Hank: Oh, my God!
Wil: This is an amazing time to be alive!
Australian money says "but fart" on it.
There was a fog of farts around.
It was a Fartmas Miracle.
Hank: Fartmas is trending worldwide!
Hank, Matthew, Michael: Lighting up farts,
running away, burn down your house on Fartmas
Day!
Hank: And remember that we are all but farts
in the butt of Butfartman.
Link Neal: we wanna say that we appreciate
what you've done to create this outlet.
Joia Mukherjee: We need all of us to work
together and say we're in this for the long-haul.
Ettore Rossetti: Thank you and your community
for the time and contributions...
you're truly awesome, as your name suggests.
Hank: Thank you to everyone so much for making
this year's Project for Awesome so successful,
and so awesome: we had six trending hashtags,
dozens of guests who donated tens of thousands
of perks, hundreds of thousands of votes on
over 900 videos submitted, and we raised $1,282,750
to make the world make a little bit more sense.
Thank you so much!
This community is the best!
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.